[Musique]
une légende raconte qu'un jour
détrôné par son frère pygmalion la
princesse phénicienne
elissa qui t'attire pour fonder une
nouvelle vide en afrique
arrivé au comptoir phénicien du titre
ellis a voulu acheter un territoire
limitrophe s'avançant dans la mer
mais le seigneur local lui promit autant
de terres quillan pourrait tenir dans la
peau d'un peuvent
[Musique]
alors élise sa découpe à une peau de
boeuf en lanières très fine et les
déroula sur la surface choisie
dessinant un espace bien plus étendu que
celui qui lui étaient vendus
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que naquit carthage
la ville mère des tunisiens
[Musique]
et
tout commence en afrique centrale il y
environ 60 milles ans avec la première
grande migration des homo sapiens nos
ancêtres diraient
certains sapiens quitte le continent
pour s'installer en asie et en europe
d'autres migrent vers le sud de
l'afrique et d'autres encore vers les
côtes occidentales africaine
les sapiens qui se répartissent sur le
littoral allant du maroc à la tunisie
sont des nomades qui se nourrissent de
plantes sauvages
9 de dates et de poissons
ce sont les ancêtres et maghrébins
il y a environ quarante mille ans dans
l'oasis de el guettar leurs descendants
réalise avec des milliers d'éclats de
silex le monument religieux le plus
ancien du monde
il y a environ 15 mille ans dans le site
dell mais qd à ces gens produisent des
aiguilles en hausse pour coudre des
vêtements à partir de peaux d'animaux
ce culte de petites formes humaines en
calcaire
et grave sur la roche des figures
abstraites et des animaux
il y a environ 4000 ans le désert
saharien acquiert son climat actuel et
dans la région parviennent un grand
nombre de berbères venus du nord-est de
l'afrique et une minorité libère de
grecs
et d'italien
il y a trois mille ans arrive aussi les
phéniciens
ce sont des marins de l'ancien liban qui
lors de leur commerce avec les ibères
établissent des comptoirs sur le
littoral méditerranéen africain
le plus important de ces littoraux est
unique l'une des plus anciennes villes
de la méditerranée
deux siècles plus tard
latrines ici est en émoi
la princesse elissa première née du roi
de tyr est détrônée par son frère
pygmalion qui assassine même le mari de
celle ci
alors afin d'éviter la guerre civile
elissa et sa nombreuse suite quitte
titre
embarque des jeunes filles à l'île de
chypre et en l'an 800 14 avant notre ère
il débarque à utique
pas loin de là elissa fond de la cité
état de carthage
les nouveaux arrivent et prennent ainsi
le nom de carthaginois et s'unissant aux
autochtones berbère fond de la
civilisation punique
[Musique]
ce sont des gens pacifiques tels que les
mangeurs de lotus de l'île de djerba
rencontrées par ulysse comme le raconte
au maire dans son odyssée
mais quand les carthaginois conquiert la
péninsule ibérique
s'étendant dans la méditerranée
occidentale
ils sont repoussés par les grecs
les carthaginois tally aux étrusques
épate les graines
cependant ils doivent tous faire face à
rome une nouvelle puissance
expansionniste
[Musique]
les romains admire les carthaginois pour
leur talent d'agriculteurs
mais comme les deux villes s'accroissent
en même temps devenant rival les traités
de paix vont être suivis de trois
guerres puniques
la première de ces guerres a lieu pour
la possession du détroit de messine
que les romains ont pris d'abord aux
grecs et ensuite aux carthaginois
la deuxième guerre punique éclatent
quand le général carthaginois hannibal
barca
rentrer en italie
à la bataille de cannes
considéré comme l'une des manoeuvres
tactiques les plus réussies de
l'histoire militaire
les romains subissent plus désastreuse
des faits
mais le général romain scipion
l'africain
même des contre attaques en ibérie
débarque en afrique du nord et s'alliant
à macinnis le roi berbère de numidie
défait les carthaginois à zama
cependant les romains craignent encore
les carthaginois
alors suite aux propos de caton l'ancien
d'arthas doit être détruite
prom déclenché la troisième guerre
punique
les troupes de scipion emilien débarque
à carthage la brûle et sur le territoire
conquis la république romaine établi la
province d'afrique avec utic comme
capitale
quand rome devient un empire
l'empereur auguste reconstruit carthage
faisant d'elle la capitale de la
province romaine d'afrique
carthage redevient alors riche et
puissante
somport fourni à rome blé et huile
d'olive
la ville devient le siège la
civilisation de l'afrique romaine
carrefour du monde antique et la
romanisation apporta dense réseau de
sites et de thé d'amphithéâtre de
bâtiments publics et de riches villas
privées au sol couvert de mosaïque
la langue officielle de la province
d'afrique est le latin mais la langue
punique demeure en usage jusqu'à l'an
les cultes odieux punique baal amont et
tanit
s'amalgament tu occultes polythéistes
romain
au début du 4e siècle tout change
l'empereur romain constantin
embrasse le christianisme qui devient
alors la religion officielle de l'empiré
romain et de ses provinces
des berbères chrétiens instruit des
civilisés tels que tertullien saint
cyprien et saint-augustin fond de la
province d'afrique un centre
d'évangélisation majeur de l' empire
romain
cependant le siècle suivant la donne
change à nouveau
des nomades venant de mongolie les
terribles 1 arrive et saccagent le nord
de l'europe repoussant en masse les
peuples germaniques dans l' empire
romain
[Musique]
c'est le chaos
l'empiré romain trop vaste pour être
bien défendue est alors divisé en deux
l'empiré romain d'occident et l' empire
romain d'orient aussi appelé empire
byzantin
mais l'invasion des germains est
impossible à arrêter
certaines de leurs peuplades entre dans
la péninsule italienne
tandis que les germains vandales et
alain traverse la gaule et l'hispanie
pour s'établir au nord de l'afrique
leur chef jean série
établissons royaume à carthage mais
comme il est adepte de l'arianisme une
doctrine chrétienne hérétiques il n'est
pas accepté par les carthaginois
chrétien est fréquemment attaqués par
les tribus païenne de berbères chablis
[Musique]
alors genserix
réagi cruellement il persécute les
chrétiens mais les carthaginois en
esclavage exil deux portes de taxes
torture les nobles et confisquer leurs
biens
cependant les vandales sont aussi des
patrons du savoir car leur école
accueille des écrivains des
scientifiques parmi les plus novateurs
de l'époque
entre-temps brom centre du christianisme
est saccagée par les germains et rule
qui dépose le dernier empereur romain
d'occident
mais l'empereur byzantin justinien
intervient militairement et
reconquièrent l'italie en commençant par
le contrôle de la méditerranée
justinien envoie à carthage le général
bélizaire qui bat définitivement les
vandales et en englobant la province
africaine dans l' empire byzantin
rétabli l'église chrétienne de carthage
[Musique]
cela n'empêche pas les principautés
berbère jamais dompter d'attaquer les
byzantins depuis le désert et les
montagnes
[Musique]
en
l'an 600 47 tout change à nouveau
l'armée de l'islam une nouvelle fois
fondée en arabie par le prophète mahomet
envahi le nord de l'afrique
le général arabe et belle nafie
fonds de la ville de kairouan
la dotant d'une grande mosquée
mais il est attaqué par les berbères
mauritanien du roi causé il a qui
occupent guerre ou ans et par les
byzantins qui reprennent carthage
[Musique]
cependant en l'an 680 18
ils sont tous définitivement battu par
la très puissante armée des omeyyades
d'une dynastie arabe sunnite originaire
de lamèque
c'est le début de l'ère musulmane
en afrique
pu
embaucher
les
les omeyyades appel maghreb les terres
des berbères
désignant avec ce terme le couchant
l'occident et appelle ifriqiya la région
qui correspond à l'actuelle tunisie du
nom de la tribu berbère des afridi qui
vit près de carthage et de leur divinité
ifri
cependant
bien qu'ils embrassent l'islam
les berbères ne s'avoue toujours pas
vaincu
habitué à un système communautaire il a
des rocky ridge isme une hérésie de
l'islam qui proclame l'égalité des
musulmans sans distinction de race ni de
classe
bientôt les kirill gîte du royaumes
berbères su frites de tlemcen se rebelle
mais ils sont anéantis par les omeyyades
qui fonde qu'à rouen la capitale de
l'ifriqiya
[Musique]
carthage
abandonné
est alors remplacé par un comptoir fondé
mille ans auparavant par les phéniciens
la citadelle de tunis qui devient dès
lors une ville portuaire importante orné
de la mosquée zitouna
les omeyyades sont si puissants qu'ils
conquièrent la péninsule ibérique
l'appel al-andalus et s'y installent
confiant ainsi le maghreb tout entier à
la dynastie abbassides
à cette époque l'état de l'ifriqiya est
gouverné par la dynastie arabe d'eagles
habib fondateur de la grande ville de
rakkada et les villes fortifiées de sfax
sousse et monastir
[Musique]
les ags l'avide possède aussi une forte
flotte de combat
et prennent malte et la sicile aux
byzantins mais reconnaissent la
souveraineté du khalife abbassides
auquel il verse annuellement des
redevances
[Musique]
entre temps le différend qui divise
l'islam en sunnites et chiites
s'intensifie
le shit ubayd allah al mahdi fondateur
de la dynastie des fatimides
déclare usurpateurs les qualifs de
sunnites et face seul émirat hague la
bid se proclame qualifs et sur un
littoral de l'ifriqiya fonde sa capitale
mahdia
[Musique]
l'un de ses successeurs
le calife fatimide à lui
bon caire l'egypte
bond lequel il francs pour sa capitale
et s'y installe confiant le gouvernement
de l'ifriqiya
abu login et bunny nsiri fondateur de la
dynastie des zirides
[Musique]
cependant quand les zirides réclame
l'indépendance le calife fatimide dresse
à leur encontre les hilaliens
des tribus de nomades égyptiens qui
arrive en ifriqiya
dévastent les domaines agricoles pillent
les villages et occupe des roues en
obligeant les zirides à se réfugier à
mahdia
mais l'ifriqiya est aussi convoité par
des puissances maritimes européennes
amiens est saccagée par les armes et des
républiques de pise et de gênes et le
littoral de l'ifriqiya est occupée par
les normands qui ont chassé les
musulmans de la sicile
alertée la ville de tunis à peine à
l'heure à l'aide les amadid
une dynastie dérivés des zirides qui
désigne en tant que gouverneur de tunis
ap dallerac yven cours à son fondateur
de la dynastie des cours hassan id
les cours hassanine tiennent à l'écart
les hilaliens repousse des normands et
érige l'ifriqiya un principauté
indépendante
mais les berbères sont toujours à
l'affût
depuis le maroc une révolte berbère se
structure en empire et en formant la
dynastie almohade
s'empare de la lampe da luz et du
maghreb
les almohades chasse définitivement les
normands
permettent à l'ifriqiya de devenir le
plus puissant des états nord africain du
moyen-âge et en confie le gouvernement à
abdal wahid ebay abyss
son fils abou zakaria fondateur de la
dynastie des al sid
profitent de la défaite des almohades
contre les espagnols prend tunis pour
capitale et se proclame souverain de
l'ifriqiya qui prend alors le nom de
tunisie
[Musique]
entre dans
l'anatolie est devenue musulmane
le bay turkmène haussmann fraunié à
former l'empiré ottoman est envahie
l'empiré byzantin y compris la ville
sacrée des chrétiens jérusalem
les papes de rome
alertée appelle alors les nobles
européens aux croisades
plusieurs armées chrétiennes parts dont
pour libérer le moyen orient
et pendant la seconde croisade le roi de
france louis 9
appelé saint-louis débarque en tunisie
pour conquérir d'autres pays arabes
baie saint louis et une grande partie de
ces hommes sont tués par la presse
bientôt aux almohades succès les
mérinides dabou hinan faris
qui conquiert la tunisie déjà affaibli
par la fesse les invasions hilalienne et
surtout par les attaques des s'ouvre
accattoli et d'aragon et de casting qui
attaquent mers-el-kébir oran bougies et
tripoli
la cité de tunis appelle alors à l'aide
les corsaires tels que les fameux frères
barberousse
harout barberousse obtient du sultan de
tunis le port de la goulette sous
condition de lui laisser un tiers du
butin et a taclé flotte espagnole
italienne et pontificale
mais meurt pendant la bataille
son frère
khaïr eddine
s'empare alors de tunis et visant la
protection ottomane se déclare vassal de
soliman le magnifique
le sultan turc qui aspirent à englober
le maghreb dans l' empire ottoman
mais khayrat dean est battu par le très
puissant charles quint d'apps bourg m de
lempire sur lequel le soleil ne se
couche jamais
héritier du saint-empire romain
germanique du royaume d'espagne et de
ses colonies
charles quint mais la tunisie sous
tutelle espagnol
mais son fils philippe ii d'espagne en
conflit avec les souverains d'europe se
désintéresse bientôt du maghreb
reconnaissante aux ottomans la régence
de la tunisie de l'algérie de la
cyrénaïque et de la tripolitaine
[Musique]
c'est la période de la tunisie ottomane
son région est mourad ben est née
giacomo senti un corse capturer enfants
par des pirates est élevé par le bey de
tunis l'ancien mamelouks romdhane
les mamelouks sont les membres d'une
milice formée d'esclaves affranchis et
les baies sont les souverains musulmans
mourad ben et fonde la dynastie moore a
dit et obtient du gouvernement ottoman
le droit de transmettre sa charge par
héritage
mais quand ses successeurs réclame
l'indépendance
le sultan ottoman les renverse
proclamant baie de tunis le commandant
de la milice turc hussein ben ali
l'un de ses successeurs ahmed 1er mai
amène la tunisie à l'autonomie
sous son règne le pays est à vis la
première constitution du monde arabe
créer sa propre monnaie
et une arme et indépendante
adopte le drapeau tunisien
est aboli l esclavage
mais dans le reste du maghreb
l'ingérence étrangère et pesant
la france un ex l'algérie
et l'espagne occupe le maroc
la difficulté financière qui étrangle le
maghreb aggrave la situation en tunisie
quand celle ci impose la hausse des
impôts à ses citoyens il déclenche d'une
insurrection sanglante
la constitution est alors suspendu la
tunisie fait banqueroute et cela profite
à la france à l'italie et au royaume uni
la france souhaite sécuriser les
frontières de l'algérie contre les
pillages des montagnards tunisien
[Musique]
le tout nouveau royaume d'italie
aspire à coloniser la tunisie où les
italiens sont nombreux
[Musique]
le royaume uni ne veut pas que la flotte
commerciale italienne soit active en
méditerranée méridionale
surtout autour du canal de suez
ainsi au congrès de berlin
l'allemagne et le royaume-uni permettent
à la france de placer la tunisie sous un
régime de protectorat
c'est la période de la tunisie française
sous le contrôle d'un général français
le pays conserve son gouvernement mais
l'administration est dirigé par des
fonctionnaires français qui gère la
politique étrangère la défense et les
affaires internes
le protectorat français permet des
progrès économiques
les banques et les entreprises
tunisiennes se consolide
le réseau ferroviaire se renforce
bizerte devient un important port
militaire et dans le domaine de
l'éducation
la france établit un système bilingue
arabe français
cela permet à l'élite tunisienne de se
former dans les deux langues
mais la domination étrangère n'est pas
accepté par le peuple tunisien
héritier du fort esprit indépendant des
berbères
la rébellion débutée dans les rues avec
le mouvement nationaliste les jeunes
tunisiens fondée par béchir phare alice
h en bas et abdelaziz saoud
ils sont tous exilés et la presse
anticolonialiste est interdite
la france ressert les taux peut en vivre
ses colonies en état d'urgence
quand soudainement la première guerre
mondiale éclate
à la fin de la guerre les ottomans et
les allemands sont des fêtes
les nationalistes turcs de mettre fin à
l' empire ottoman
pour sa part la france conserve ses
colonies
en tunisie
abdelaziz thaalbi
s'oppose alors à la domination française
font dans le parti politique du destour
mais est contraint à la clandestinité
c'est alors qu'arrive l'avocat habib ben
ali bourguiba
formé en france est revenu en tunisie
pour prôner l'indépendance et la laïcité
du peuple tunisien
bourguiba
critique durement le régime français et
font avec tahar sfar mahmoud el materi
et barry guiga le journal l'action
tunisienne alimentant le mouvement
national
le destour
revigoré se dédouble alors en un parti
politique islamisant qui conserve le nom
destour est en parti laïc le néo destour
guidé par bourguiba
[Musique]
le néo destour est structurée sur les
modèles des partis socialistes européens
et tente de convaincre l'opinion
française mais bourguiba est emprisonné
en france pour conspiration contre la
sûreté de l'état
entre temps un autre grand conflit se
prépare
[Musique]
la volonté d'hitler de reconstituer
l'ancien empire allemand fait éclater la
seconde guerre mondiale
[Musique]
les allemands occupent l'europe et
libère bourguiba l'envoyant en italie ou
mussolini attend son aide pour affaiblir
la présence française en afrique du nord
mais bourguiba n'apprécie pas le
fascisme
il espère la victoire des alliés anglo
américain ou obtenir l'indépendance de
la tunisie
et quand la grande guerre se termine
les alliés chasse les couples allemande
d'europe et d'afrique
la france libre déclare alors la
quatrième république
garde ses colonies et la tunisie reste
un protectorat français
[Musique]
bourguiba
clandestins en egypte ne renonce pas à
la lutte pour la construction d'un état
tunisien libre son parti le néo destour
s'allie au syndicat de l'union générale
tunisienne du travail
fondée par farhat hached et approuve le
comité national de la résistance d'une
hygiène fondée par ahmed tlili
la france emprisonne bourguiba revenus
d'égypte les membres du néo destour
mêmes lamine bey qui règne sur la
tunisie pour le compte de la france
quand farhad à chaîne est assassiné par
l'organisation contre-terrorisme de la
main rouge
l'insurrection tunisienne éclats
les colons les entreprises françaises et
les structures gouvernementales sont
durement attaqué
la france fait un pas en arrière avec le
discours de carthage du ministre
mendès-france qui prône l'indépendance
de la tunisie
à ce discours
succèdent l'accord entre le président du
conseil français edgar faure et le chef
de l'état tunisien tahar ben ammar qui
récupère toutes les compétences à
l'exception de celle des affaires
étrangères et de la défense
finalement après d'autres négociations
le 20 mars
1956 la france reconnaît l'indépendance
de la tunisie tout en conservant la base
militaire de bizerte
à l'assemblée constituante tunisienne
le néo destour remporte tous les sièges
et bourguiba est élu premier ministre du
royaume de lamine bey
[Musique]
la tunisie adhère alors ou nations unies
aboli la monarchie
et le 8 novembre
1959 bourguiba est élu premier président
de la république tunisienne
pour moi l'indépendance n'a tunisie
c'est une chose sérieuse se contente pas
d apparence
indépendant souverain doit l'être sur
tout son territoire
ainsi
la france quitte la base militaire de
bizerte et bourguiba
auréolé du titre de combattant suprême
met sur pied un état moderne
il développe l'éducation et l'économie
nationalise les terres agricoles
combat la pauvreté
[Musique]
réduit les inégalités entre hommes et
femmes
et améliore la politique étrangère
en même temps
son régime de parti unique utilise la
force et permet la corruption
à l'université de tunis
bourguiba est fortement cliniques et
des camps son ancien lieutenant et ami
salah ben youssef
l'accusent de reniements et de trahison
à l'égard du peuple tunisien bourguiba
le fait assassiner
ce désordre favorise el nahdha un
mouvement islamiste conservateur
fortement combattue par le premier
ministre zine el abidine ben ali
fondateur du rassemblement
constitutionnel démocratique
afin de se débarrasser au plus vite des
conservateurs islamistes ben ali d pose
bourguiba l'accusant d' à capacité à
assumer ses fonctions pour cause de
sénilité
puis en tant que son successeur
constitutionnel
assume le rôle de président de la
république tunisienne et de chef suprême
des forces armées
[Musique]
ben ali emprisonne des milliers de
militants de hay nahda
relance l'économie tunisienne en signant
un accord de libre échange avec l'union
européenne
par la suite il est largement réélu
président de la république mais son
régime devient bientôt totalitaire
en supprimant la limite les trois
mandats présidentiels benali introduit
sa propre immunité judiciaire à vie et
accroît son pouvoir personnel
ceci favorise la corruption et cause une
grande crise sociale
en signe de protestation
le jeune chômeur mohamed bouazizi ce
suicide à sidi bouzid déclenchant une
révolte qui s'étend immédiatement aux
autres villes du pays
c'est la révolution tunisienne
[Musique]
appelée révolution du jasmin elle se
déroule par une suite de manifestations
et de sit in que les forces de police
réprime avec du gaz lacrymogène et des
balles en caoutchouc
en vain car toutes les classes sociales
tunisiennes exigent maintenant la
destitution de ben ali
il est alors remplacé
par son premier ministre mohamed
ghanouchi
lui aussi est critiquée et
démocratiquement remplacé par béji caïd
essebsi
sous la présidence de caïd essebsi
le quatuor constitué du dialogue
national
composé de l'union générale tunisienne
du travail
de l'union tunisienne de l'industrie du
commerce et de l'artisanat
du conseil de l'ordre national des
avocats de tunisie
et de la ligue tunisienne des droits de
l'homme
obtient le prix nobel de la paix 2015
[Applaudissements]
ban ki moon secrétaire général des
nations unies déclarent que ce prix est
dédié aux tunisiens qui ont participé au
printemps arabe
le président caïd essebsi rédiger une
nouvelle constitution
et aux élections comme les islamistes
d'ennahda s'engagent à combattre la
corruption
ils obtiennent la majorité relative
ennahda obtient enfin la majorité
absolue en s'alliant avec le congrès
pour la république un parti de gauche
nationaliste
et avec ettakatol un parti social
démocrate
aux élections suivantes
ils perdent la moitié de leurs électeurs
car contrairement aux promesses faites
ennahda s'allie au coeur de la tunisie
le parti politique de nabil karoui
propriétaire de chaînes de télévision
privées soupçonnées de blanchiment
d'argent et d'évasion fiscale
bien que très âgées le président s est
psy s'oppose à cette coalition créant le
parti politique ni date où naissent
appel de la tunisie
mais décède avant la fin de son mandat
[Musique]
l'entrepreneur nabil karoui
concours pour la présidentielle mais la
démocratie électorale tunisienne
lui préfère un nouveau venu dans le
monde politique le professeur kaïssa end
c'est un juriste et universitaires
spécialistes du droit constitutionnel
défenseur d'une vision conservatrice
d'une forme de souveraineté nationale et
d'une démocratie non centralisés
conformément à la constitution
le président de la république tunisienne
kaïs sai et proposa à big jay nolly
désigné par le parti majoritaire
ennnahda de former un nouveau
gouvernement
mais l'assemblée des représentants du
peuple tunisien refuse sa confiance à
abidjan m li gars ennahda est impliqué
dans des assassinats politiques
de plus l'état islamique revendique les
attaques terroristes en tunisie qui ont
causé plusieurs morts et blessés
alors le président sayed propose à
l'ingénieur et liste apfa membres du
parti ettakatol de former un nouveau
gouvernement
[Musique]
fatfat accepte mais comme ils tentent de
remplacer les ministres membres
d'ennahdha il est accusé de conflit
d'intérêts et il démissionne
le rôle de chef du gouvernement passe
alors à -sh m mais ccici qui annonce un
remaniement ministériel et une
modification de plusieurs fonctions
gouvernementales
[Musique]
cette fois ci c'est le président ça y
est de lui même qui refusent de nouveau
gouvernement
contenant selon lui des personnalités
soupçonnées de corruption et de non
respect de la constitution
il invoque alors l'article 80 de la
constitution et bloque le parlement
tunisien
déclarant qu'à danger imminent menace
l'intégrité du pays
puis il décrète la loi relative à
l'organisation temporaire politique et
nomme premier ministre du gouvernement
tunisien une ingénieur universitaire
madame najlae bouden qui entre dans
l'histoire en tant que première femme à
exercer ce poste dans le monde arabe
enfin
dans un climat démocratique où aucun
parti politique d' est interdite
aucune personne n'est arrêté pour ses
opinions
et où l'opposition a le droit de
manifester
le président de la république kaïs sayed
soutenu par la grande majorité du peuple
tunisien remplace le conseil supérieur
de la magistrature
par un conseil transitoire dont il n'est
pas membre
promeut un référendum sur la nouvelle
constitution
et convoque les élections législatives
voilà donc
la grande histoire de la tunisie
sur ses terres millénaire sont nés le
général ali balle
considéré comme l'un des plus grands
tacticiens militaire de l'histoire
l'érudit magon
rédacteur d'un traité sur l'agriculture
qui est le seul ouvrage que les romains
est ramenée à rome après la destruction
de carthage
[Musique]
le poète a pu les hauteurs de
métamorphose un chef-d'oeuvre qui a
fasciné les poètes du monde entier
le philosophe et théologien chrétiens
augustin d'hippone devenu saint-augustin
connu comme le penseur le plus influent
du monde occidental
le philosophe ibn khaldoun dont les
ouvrages sont parmi les plus
intéressantes et produits l'esprit
humain
et de nombreux autres personnages
remarquables qui perpétue le génie
tunisien dans le monde
[Musique]
cela aurait ravi la princesse
phénicienne elissa qui en déroulant les
lanières d'une peau de boeuf sur une co
lead descendant vers la mer a donné
naissance à un peuple jamais soumis est
très fier de sa propre identité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]